en vídeos anteriores aquí en visual
político hemos hablado ya de china en
los últimos años la presencia de china
en el continente africano sólo en
pakistán china que se ha hecho también
con el puerto de gwadar el caso más
característico es sin lugar a dudas el
bichi hemos visto como este país se ha
convertido en el mayor socio comercial
de áfrica superando incluso a los
mismísimos eeuu o como el gigante
asiático está llevando a cabo el mayor
proyecto de infraestructuras de la
historia que conocido como la nueva ruta
de la seda tendrá implicaciones muy
importantes en asia central oriente
medio e incluso en europa sin embargo
hay otra región prioritaria para los
líderes chinos que no podemos olvidar
latinoamérica a sus amigos sino también
está apostando fuerte por el continente
latinoamericano en este vídeo vamos a
ver qué está ocurriendo
el desembarco chino en la américa latina
está siendo enorme en los últimos 15
años las relaciones comerciales entre
china y latinoamérica se han
multiplicado por 22 hasta superar en
2015 los 230 mil millones de dólares hoy
china es ya el segundo mayor socio
comercial de la región el tercer mayor
inversor y el mayor prestamista y por
cierto todo apunta a que el liderazgo
comercial que eeuu aún mantiene sucumbir
a pronto ante el empuje del gigante
asiático si no ha prometido incrementar
su comercio bilateral con la región a
500 mil millones de dólares en 2025 de
hecho a día de hoy china ya es el mayor
socio comercial de países tan destacados
como brasil perú o chile y junto a esa
tendencia económica encontramos la
política
latinoamérica es una prioridad para
pekín y las autoridades chinas no han
dudado en darle a la región un rol
destacado como pues por ejemplo el
presidente chino xi jinping desde que
asumió la presidencia en 2013 ha
realizado tres giras por la región más
que cualquier presidente anterior de
china de hecho
xi jinping entre 2013 y 2016 habrá
visitado 10 países latinoamericanos
tantos como obama pero eso sí en la
mitad de tiempo
y os preguntaréis cuál es el objetivo de
tantos viajes pues fundamentalmente
estimular las relaciones comerciales
porque curiosamente como ya vimos en los
casos de áfrica y la ruta de la seda el
comercio es la prioridad absoluta de la
política exterior china por su parte los
líderes latinoamericanos que cada vez le
otorgan una mayor relevancia a la
inversión en sus políticas de desarrollo
también han comenzado a frecuentar pekín
una ciudad que cada vez juega un mayor
rol en las relaciones internacionales la
mejor muestra de esta tendencia ha sido
la decisión de pedro pablo kuczynski el
presidente de perú que escogió a china
como destino de su primer viaje oficial
no estamos buscando créditos ayuda
financiera lo que estamos buscando es
inversión y cooperación a nivel
internacional es verdad hubo un momento
en el que parecía que china se acercaba
sobre todo a los países dominados por
gobiernos de izquierdas o de corte
populista pero la verdad amigos es que
eso no es en absoluto algo que le
importe a pekín más allá eso sí de que
estos países suelen mantener
peores relaciones con washington en este
mismo lugar huele a azufre todavía por
lo que evidentemente suelen resultar más
accesibles pero nada más hasta el
momento china ha firmado tratados de
libre comercio con perú chile y costa
rica y actualmente mantiene
conversaciones con colombia y el bloque
que conforman mercosur lo que dijo el
señor chino que vino el otro día la
propuesta que nos hizo que lean ese
discurso detenidamente que nunca yo no
me acuerdo que en américa latina nadie
vino a hablarnos a proponer nuestras
cosas y es un envite de características
globales como nunca hemos tenido y no
debemos dejar perder esa oportunidad así
que todo apunta que en poco tiempo las
trabas al comercio habrán desaparecido
los objetivos del gobierno chino
precisamente van en esa línea y son muy
ambiciosos en los próximos diez años
quieren doblar las relaciones
comerciales y multiplicar por tres las
inversiones chinas en américa latina'
sin ir más lejos en 2015 xi jinping
anunció que tiene invertirán
al menos 250.000 millones de dólares en
los próximos 10 años
y además aunque hasta ahora algunos son
las inversiones se habían concentrado en
los sectores ligados a los recursos
naturales y la obra pública cada vez es
más habitual que las empresas chinas
comiencen a operar en este territorio o
compren directamente empresas
latinoamericanas de diferentes sectores
compañías de petróleo de electricidad
bancos o incluso empresas de explotación
pesqueras el dinero chino comienza a
llover sobre todo tipo de negocios
trump latinoamérica y china un nuevo
tablero de juego
todo esto ocurre justo en un momento en
el que parece que washington con la
nueva administración trump nos sitúa
precisamente latinoamérica con una
prioridad estratégica de hecho lo sabéis
mientras que el gobierno chino no deja
de hablar de inversiones mutuas y
aperturismo el nuevo presidente de eeuu
dedicó gran parte de su campaña a
criticar el comercio con méxico y a
prometer deportaciones y muros lo cierto
es que no muchas palabras cariñosas
hacia américa latina por su parte de la
red
en el de bering así que nada me clay de
ganar al frente de la mente de aquel en
el que nada metro y está además el
asunto del pp sobre el cual don al tram
ha dicho que se opone a su ratificación
y este tratado afecta a varios países
latinoamericanas pues bien china lleva
tiempo trabajando en una alternativa al
mismo en la zona de asia oceanía pero
claro a tenor de los acontecimientos ya
se está hablando que podría incluir
también a países de américa latina se
conoce como asociación económico
integral regional y si finalmente eeuu
no ratifica el pp podría convertirse en
la referencia económica del pacífico y
claro como podéis imaginar en ese caso
el protagonismo y el liderazgo requería
en pekín con washington
si eeuu no quiere el pp nosotros vamos a
buscar un acuerdo sin eeuu que incluye a
china y también a rusia y ojo si hay un
país que despierta la obsesión de trump
ese china
anoche pues todo esto no sería extraño
que en poco tiempo el tablero de disputa
entre china y eeuu se extendiese a
latinoamérica bien pero esta relación
con china es buena o es mala estoy
convencido de que esta es la pregunta
que muchos os estáis haciendo así que
tratemos de responderla riesgos y
amenazas
del 80% de las exportaciones de américa
latina china recaen en una agricultura
que en general genera poco valor añadido
y en la minería que es una actividad
poco intensiva en mano de obra
la soja el cobre el petróleo y el hierro
son los cuatro productos que dominan las
exportaciones latinoamericanas o china
por contra el grueso de las
importaciones corresponde a productos
industriales así que aquí vemos un
primer problema si latinoamericano
afronta reformas en favor de la
competitividad esta integración
comercial puede traducirse en una
desindustrialización creciente y en un
modelo económico que genere pocos
empleos por no hablar del déficit
comercial que a tenor de esta situación
crece año a año por segundo año
consecutivo bolivia tiene un déficit
comercial el tercer trimestre del año
con 835 millones de dólares un segundo
problema tiene que ver con los préstamos
que china viene realizando a los
gobiernos de la región china es exigente
con los acuerdos que firma de tal forma
que fija siempre tipos de interés
bastante altos y para garantizarse el
cobro suele contemplar el pago en
especie por ejemplo gran parte de los
préstamos que china le ha hecho al
gobierno de correa en ecuador serán
reintegrados en petróleo esto hace que
la presión financiera sobre los
gobiernos sea menor así al cabo no
necesitan dinero pagan con recursos
naturales pero que nadie se llame a
engaño los intereses implícitos son
altos muy altos y chinas
además también suelo obligar a que los
proyectos sean realizados por empresas
chinas y con tecnología también china
calcula que china domina ya un tercio
del sector minero peruano en concreto en
la explotación de cobre siendo las
empresas asiáticas las mayores
productoras de este mineral en el país
el resultado es que si los gobiernos
latinoamericanos tienen la tentación de
gastar más de la cuenta o no evalúan
correctamente en los proyectos en que
van a invertir el dinero prestado pueden
encontrarse con un escenario donde la
explotación de sus recursos naturales
acabe en manos de pekín y por supuesto
china tiene suficiente influencia y
poder como para lograr que todos los
préstamos se paguen aquí no cabe hablar
de auditorías de la deuda de moratoria
ni de suspensiones de pago por último
existe también cierta preocupación con
que los cuestionables modos de trabajos
chinos en terrenos como las normas
ambientales o la opaca gestión
empresarial puedan extenderse por el
continente o también consolidar la pobre
consideración hacia la seguridad en el
trabajo hasta aquí los riesgos
oportunidades para latinoamérica por
supuesto junto a yo también son muchas
las oportunidades que abren las
relaciones con el gigante asiático china
puede facilitar la latinoamérica los
recursos que este continente necesita
para financiar infraestructuras e
industrias esenciales y además les
ofrece a sus empresas el acceso a un
mercado gigantesco prácticamente podemos
decir que china es una alternativa a
washington y a donald trump
personalmente estoy convencido de que
china puede jugar un papel muy positivo
en latinoamérica siempre y cuando claro
sus gobiernos aprovechen estas
relaciones para impulsar el comercio
atraer a inversiones y modernizar sus
estructuras productivas ese es el reto
bien tú qué opinas de américa latina'
abrazarse a china tolerar a donald trump
que pekín asuma tanto protagonismo en
esta región o tratará de impedirlo
espero vuestras respuestas y como
siempre os decimos si aún no estás
suscritos podéis hacerlo ahora pulsando
sobre este botón os prometimos que en
visual política estaremos muy atentos a
todos los movimientos del gigante chino
un saludo y hasta la próxima amigos
en realidad